Transcription: morgane helstroffer
Relecteur: eric vautier
(Bruit de machine)
Je suis né
sur un petit joyau vert du Pacifique.
La Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Et quand j'étais enfant,
j'ai eu la chance
de grandir parmi nos cow-boys,
ces grands éleveurs de bétail,
et en tribu
avec nos fiers guerriers mélanésiens.
On m'a donc rapidement appris
à vivre de la nature,
à rentrer le bétail à cheval,
chasser le cerf ou le cochon sauvage,
pêcher,
ou encore reconnaître
les plantes médicinales et comestibles.
En revanche,
dès que les parents tournaient le dos,
je me gavais de bonbons,
de chips et de sodas,
tous bien chimiques,
toujours à la recherche
de ma dose de sucre.
En sachant qu'ici on met quand même
du miel sur du sucre,
autant vous dire que
j'ai fait quelques petits excès.
Et moi,
qui voulais être un guerrier
comme nos anciens,
défenseur de la nature et des hommes,
me voilà devenu...
guerrier diabétique.
Cette maladie des temps modernes.
Alors bon,
je peux m'évanouir à tout moment,
tel un fier guerrier moderne,
mais ne vous inquiétez pas,
Je vais essayer de finir ma présentation.
La Nouvelle-Calédonie était connue
dans le monde entier
pour ses produits d'exception.
Le fameux café Leroy,
et autres Bourbons,
le plus haut taux de vanilline,
le cacao connu jusqu'en Afrique,
le santal pour la grande parfumerie,
et il y en a tellement d'autres !
Nous avons la chance
de vivre dans un paradis
avec une population peu nombreuse,
une nature connue
pour sa richesse écologique,
son record d'endémicité, son lagon
et sa barrière de corail si riches.
Nous pourrions construire
notre économie sur la biodiversité,
et être même
une référence écologique dans le monde.
Pourtant,
l'industrie minière est aujourd'hui
le moteur principal de l'économie locale.
D'ailleurs,
quelle est la marchandise la plus échangée
au monde après le pétrole ?
Le nickel ? Non.
Le sucre ? Eh non plus.
C'est le café.
Le café a été découvert
il y a plus de mille ans,
entre le Yémen et l’Éthiopie.
Sa consommation s'est diffusée
très rapidement sur notre planète
pour finalement arriver
en 1856 sur notre île.
Notre café était bu
par les grands passionnés,
nos ministres et présidents.
L'histoire raconte même
qu'il devint le préféré de Churchill.
C'était un café rare et prestigieux.
Et c'est cultivé
sous ombrage de nos forêts
que l'on arrive à notre pic de production,
en 1939,
où l'on exporte plus de 2 000 tonnes
à travers le monde.
Le déclin de cette production
commence avec l'envolée
des cours du nickel
à la fin des années 60,
où c'est plus d'un tiers de la population
qui se tourne vers l'industrie minière.
Finalement,
c'est avec la mise en place
de la fameuse « opération café soleil »
que la production chute en dix ans
à moins de 100 tonnes.
(Bruit de machine)
Faire du café soleil,
c'est planter du café en plein soleil.
Et les anciens racontent
que pour le faire,
les ingénieurs et leurs équipes
avaient rasé à coup de bulldozers
la plupart de nos anciennes cafeiries,
plantées sous ombrage.
Une aberration écologique
qui a permis de faire tourner
l'agro-industrie
en utilisant le cercle vicieux
de cette agriculture qui n'a aucun sens.
Le café ne pousse pas naturellement
en plein soleil.
Il végète, donne moins, meurt plus vite
et tous les 10 ans,
on doit renouveler les pieds
qu'il faut acheter aux pépinières.
Alors que naturellement,
il vit sous couvert d'une forêt humide
où l'on trouve des pieds de plus de 50 ans
qui fructifient toujours,
et sous lesquels on trouve
une véritable nurserie naturelle.
Sous le soleil,
on doit installer
tout un réseau d'irrigation,
nourrir les pieds,
les protéger avec des engrais,
des fongicides et des désherbants.
Sous ombrage,
c'est la forêt
qui apporte les besoins en humidité
et la matière organique
que champignons et bactéries dégradent
pour nourrir les caféiers.
C'est aussi la forêt
qui les protège des cyclones
et qui possède
toute une panoplie d'organismes vivants
pour lutter naturellement
contre les ravageurs.
Avec la plantation sous soleil,
le producteur doit batailler
avec l'endettement
et le jeu des subventions.
En plus, on lui enlève le séchage de café
et on mélange toutes les récoltes
dans des coopératives
ou autres centrales d'achat.
Résultat : un café de qualité médiocre
et que l'on rémunère très mal.
En moyenne, ici et dans le monde,
entre 4 et 10 % de sa valeur finale.
Une misère.
Sous ombrage,
on utilise une technologie appropriée
où l'on réduit considérablement les coûts.
Chacun sèche son propre café,
puis, on le classe par qualité,
pour une plus grande valeur sur le marché.
Ici en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
certains rémunèrent
entre 40 et 50 % de sa valeur finale,
soit dix fois plus
que les rémunérations habituelles.
Il est alors facile d'entrer
dans une démarche de café de spécialité.
C'est un café
éco-responsable et équitable,
où l'on instaure une relation de confiance
entre le producteur et le consommateur,
basée sur la qualité et la transparence.
En résumé,
ce ne sont pas uniquement
les invasions de fourmis et les cyclones
qui ont arrêté la culture de café
en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
mais bien une mauvaise méthode de culture
et de rémunération des producteurs.
Alors que sous les tropiques,
l'agroforesterie est
le système agricole par excellence.
Il garantit la biodiversité la plus riche.
Sur un même espace,
on peut intégrer nos produits d'exception,
nos essences nobles et médicinales,
nos fruitiers, nos cultures vivrières,
notre maraîchage, nos plantes rampantes
sans oublier nos animaux.
En résumé,
on peut donc presque tout y mettre.
Et n'oublions pas
qu'il est quand même bien plus agréable
de travailler à l'ombre d'une forêt
qui regorge de vie et d'humidité
plutôt qu'en plein cagnard.
Et quand j'étais gamin,
parce que je viens de la côte est,
issu d'une famille qui a produit du café,
j'adorais jouer dans les cafeiries,
à l'ombre de ces grands arbres mystiques.
On construisait des cabanes,
on coursait les poules sauvages.
C'était de vrais labyrinthes,
c'était immense !
Et quand je vois aujourd'hui,
sur la Grande Terre et les îles Loyauté,
toutes ces anciennes cafeiries
encore nombreuses,
toujours debout mais inexploitées,
je comprends que cette richesse
est encore là,
construite par nos anciens,
et qu'il suffit de tendre la main
pour la cueillir
et restaurer toutes ces valeurs.
Là, je crois que les anciens
m'appellent vraiment.
Mmh-mmh.
Mmh.
Ok.
Ça fait du bien quand ça s'arrête.
(Siffle)
(Souffle)
Nous sommes aujourd'hui
à un tournant écologique planétaire
où nous reprenons conscience
de l'importance de la nature
et de sa biodiversité.
Nous pourrions intégrer ces principes
dans notre agriculture, notre élevage
et nos modes de vie.
Une solution s'offre à nous.
C'est l'agriculture naturelle.
Autrement dit, régénératrice.
C'est une agriculture saine,
qui relève du bon sens
et qui se base sur le bon développement
des écosystèmes et des populations.
On reproduit au maximum le modèle nature,
car il fonctionne et à l'infini.
On respecte ainsi le mode de vie naturel
des plantes et des animaux.
Cela s'appelle le biomimétisme.
Et il permet entre autres,
de piéger le carbone,
et donc de participer à l'inversion
du réchauffement climatique,
de générer de l'eau,
et d'assainir celle de ruissellement
qui se jette dans nos rivières,
de régénérer le sol et sa fertilité,
d'augmenter la valeur nutritive
des plantes et des animaux
et donc d'améliorer la santé
de ceux qui les consomment.
Finalement,
c'est le monde que l'on régénère.
L'agriculture régénératrice,
c'est faire bien l'agriculture,
et nous avons tous un rôle à jouer
pour la faire bien.
C'est revaloriser le rôle fondamental
de ceux qui nous nourrissent,
c'est les rémunérer équitablement,
et c'est les soutenir
à produire sainement.
Pensez maintenant à un bon café.
Et entre nous,
quand un café est vraiment bon,
on a plus besoin d'y rajouter une, deux...
trois cuillères de sucre.
C'est comme un bon whisky écossais,
12 ans d'âge,
on évite de rajouter
du soda bien sucré dedans.
Eh bien pour un bon café calédonien,
sous ombrage,
c'est pareil.
Consommer un bon café,
issu de l'agriculture régénératrice,
en plus d'être bon au goût,
c'est un symbole fort de la biodiversité
que nous mettons en place
pour produire sainement
et ça devient donc
le premier geste que nous pouvons faire
pour un futur où les femmes et les hommes
sont en bonne santé,
libérés de ces maladies modernes,
vivant sur une planète saine.
Un rêve pour moi,
mais c'est surtout un bel avenir
pour nos enfants
et nos générations futures.
Santé.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.